[Music]
sleep is crucially important and I think
we've moved from this attitude from it's
an Indulgence a waste of time almost an
illness that needs a cure to a
realization
that if you want to come up with
innovative solutions to complex problems
then a night of sleep has been clearly
demonstrated to do that for you
for something as universally important
to human life as sleep Mysteries
surrounding its necessity and utility
have only just been recently uncovered
some of our biggest discoveries were in
the 1970s or 1980s and so it makes it a
really exciting field because it seems
as though we're uncovering new insights
each and every day on the link between
our sleep and our waking success
asked a lot of people thought that it's
great to work long hours and get little
sleep with a lack of sleep sometimes
leading to 20 30 percent reduced
productivity on the next day it becomes
pretty clear that the smarter Choice
often is to sleep an hour longer than an
hour or less and though we Now
understand some of how sleep benefits
our life and health spans some
scientists are going further to find out
how sleep and what happens there can be
harnessed to further expand our
understanding
it's easy to memorize things that makes
you smart if you can spit back a lot of
facts but if you want to be wise if you
really want wisdom you got to know when
and how and why to use that information
and that's when your brain figures out
while you're sleeping there's all kinds
of things we we know dreams are related
to they're memory consolidation emotion
the next day
um but there are no studies and I mean
literally no studies which try to
manipulate those on purpose
foreign
there's no just one reason for sleep I
published a paper a couple of years ago
about this generated quite a bit of
irritation from my sleep colleagues
because the title of the paper is there
is no mystery to sleep it's a period of
physical inactivity where we have to do
a whole bunch of biology we basically
slotted that important biology to the to
the time when it is best suited when
we're not moving around interacting with
our world getting more sensory
information in in the same way people
have asked you know why do we sleep you
could equally ask I think why are we
awake is to do a whole bunch of critical
stuff all of the research shows that the
greatest benefit to our health and our
well-being is when you can consistently
make between seven and nine hours of
sleep part of your regular routine sleep
really matters for our cardiovascular
health over the course of our sleep our
blood pressure actually drops to its
lowest point in the typical 24-hour day
individuals who aren't sleeping enough
consistently are at much greater risk
for high blood pressure and then
subsequent cardiovascular disease
during sleep there's an accelerated
clearance of toxins in the brain and
that happens at a 60 increased rate that
removal of toxins during sleep than
during wakefulness we've understood the
importance of sleep because we
appreciate now what you become if you
haven't got it if you think about our
biology any biology of any organism what
it needs to do is deliver the right
materials in the right concentration to
the right tissues at the right time of
day to succeed what are circadian
systems do is give that temporal that
timing structure the analogy I've I've
made it's a bit like an orchestra you've
got lots and lots of rhythms going on
and they all need to be coordinated to
generate a symphony and of course if you
don't have that coordination if you
shoot the conductor then instead of a
symphony you have a cacophony and and
and that's what lack of a circadian
control would be you'd have you'd have
biological cacophony as human beings
we're really not built to make sweeping
changes in our sleep routine we're
really truly creatures of habit there's
also now a preponderance of evidence
that burning the candle at both ends
doesn't lead to increased productivity
the societal loss that comes with sleep
deprivation on too little sleep is about
400 billion US dollars in the United
States alone it's pretty much due to
three courses on the one hand people
with the too little sleep have a higher
mortality risk secondly there is a
workplace productivity Factor such as
increased absenteeism from work or lower
productivity at work and finally there
is also factors around skill development
the people who don't get enough sleep
suffer in their skill development
going Beyond why and how we sleep some
scientists are pushing the envelope in
terms of how we can use sleep and the
dreams that come with it to better
understand ourselves dreams in
particular serve to let us explore
possible connections between the events
of our day and and other older memories
that we might never think of connecting
them to so when we dream our brains go
looking for weakly Associated memories
that might be of potential use in
solving problems of our day and tries to
construct a narrative story of what that
might look like we might be dealing with
a co-worker or a boss at work and in a
dream at night that topic might be
activated it might connect to early
fights I had with my father and some in
particular that I remarkably close to
the fight I'm having with my boss now
and in playing out that dream the brain
calculates that this is actually a
useful Association so the next day I'm
in the office with my boss again I'm
about to say something and all of a
sudden for reasons unknown to my
conscious mind up comes this image of me
and my father having this fight and I'd
already pause and I laughed and I say to
my boss I don't think this fight really
has anything to do with you
concept is from an evolutionary point of
view the functions of dreaming occur
while we dream we never need to remember
them it's it's hard to overstate
um the kind of different brain you get
in sleeps it's totally weird your
Amnesia and your hallucinatory you're
delusional
I kind of I think got to sleep in Dreams
by being interested in
um how it was possible that someone
could get out of their own way or how it
was possible that I could be in my own
way in general how I could be multiple
people at once and how sleep was an
access point to seeing
um seeing those other people in order to
make those connections more controllable
Robert stickled Adam Harr and others at
MIT fluid interfaces have created a
process and device to implant dreams
into people as they fall asleep your
first reaction might be hey they made
Inception in real life but far from
pulling off a high-stakes dream Heist
the creators of dormio the device the
team uses to achieve targeted dream
incubation have higher-minded if less
lucrative aims targeted dream incubation
if you take away the targeted dream
incubation is a practice that's been
going on for Millennia and it's
basically a kind of Supplication or
prayer it's an ass typically in
spiritual context people before sleep
would perform a kind ritual they would
fast for a few days or they would sleep
in a holy place and that would be a way
of asking for a big dream that could be
a healing dream a dream which prescribed
a remedy could be an introspective dream
often a prophetic dream what we were
interested in is taking some of those
ideas from dream incubation and about
the kind of moment of sleep onset as a
really fertile moment to change stream
content and to add in a bit of
specificity I think there's a kind of
creepiness that some people find to the
phrase dream control and soy try to be
clear that I have there's no chance that
I can say you're gonna have a dream
where your uh Tiger Woods and then you
turn into a tree and then you feel bad
about it and then everything turns red
and like no that's not it
um what we can do is we can plan to see
basically it's a sensor
um which sits on the hand and has some
information about your heart and some
information about your muscles and some
information about your skin and the
sweat on it and it tells you a little
bit about where you are in between wake
and sleep because you don't fall asleep
all at once you fall asleep in stages in
about nine stages and so right about
when you're halfway in between those
stages it'll say hey why don't you think
about a tree literally with audio and
then it'll let you go down right about
to that ninth stage and then it'll say
hey what are you thinking about and
you'll wake up a little bit and say oh
I don't know my toes became leaves and
then you say okay you can go back to
sleep now and then it'll go right back
down about halfway do it again do it
again that's it rinse and repeat a bunch
of times so like in a 45 minute nap you
get like five or six streams usually in
terms of possible benefits for dream
incubation I think the smaller answer is
we can look at any study which has shown
us a correlation between dream content
and some kind of cognitive change and we
can say I'm gonna make that correlation
a cause so to give you an example hey it
seems like people who start dreaming in
a foreign language do better in a
foreign language course than those that
don't and then we would ask a question
oh can we help people along to start
dreaming in French in their French
language course and see then a causal
Improvement in their performance in that
course that's interesting we also have
some understanding of dreams and their
relationship to the progression of
depressive disorders or post-traumatic
stress or of anxiety disorders we have a
sense of their importance for
pre-surgery anxiety
I think the thing that's more
interesting and perhaps more important
is what happens when you leave people
with a tool that even in a very small
way can show them a part of themselves
they haven't seen before
though har and stigold are optimistic
about TDI they were part of the first
group to warn against its potential for
misuse in a letter posted in November
2021 they warned against advertisers
invading your dream space something that
was in fact already happening as a 2021
Super Bowl advertising tie-in Molson
Coors encouraged people to watch a short
video before bed featuring beer cans and
flowing Mountain Streams then listen to
an eight-hour soundscape all
incentivized with free drinks from the
company
can you tell me what you were dreaming I
was dreaming about waterfalls
it was
something to do with
pores
the alarming implications of it were
troubling to the team behind dormia so
there was a study a few years ago that
showed if you take people who wanted to
quit smoking and while they were asleep
exposed them to the mixed smells of
cigarettes and rotting fish they would
over the next couple of weeks end up
smoking only half as much cigarettes as
the control group who got no smells at
all but there's two important things to
know about that study first of all
nobody when they woke up reported
remembering having been exposed to the
smells so it was then completely out of
their waking awareness and when the
saints combined smells were played to
subjects while they were awake it had no
effect at all so what if instead of
pairing it with rotten fish they had
paired it with roses or with chocolate
you should be able to push people
towards buying more alcoholic drinks
buying more cigarettes it's the last
Sebastian of completely private in
independent World building that we have
um and let's just not give it away
simple